les vieux c'est un fouet de conservatif
mais disons que toute les trois quarts
des idées nouvelles donc qui arrivent
sont des idées qui viennent des jeunes
en général les trois quarts du temps
elles sont effrayés par qui par les
vieux
[Musique]
il y a une image et un stéréotype du des
grands-parents c'est toujours ce chez
qui on aime le plus vite
[Musique]
chez qui on se rappelle plus
gentil et c'est très bien d'avoir des
grands qui nous amène nous promener je
les aime tous nos dents et j'ai rien à
leur cacher
[Musique]
en principe on en garde toujours un
excellent souvenirs
beaucoup parce que je pouvais vraiment
me confier à eux et puis c'était comme
mes parents quoi
Isabelle
grand-parents maintenant parce que
on a l'impression que le temps court
vite c'est vrai mais on s'entoure de
quantité de d'enfants
de notre fête et puis de fait de nos
enfants qui à leur tour nous donne tous
ces petits-enfants et on a des contacts
avec trois générations en même temps
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
très vivant c'est c'est on n'arrête pas
de faire des découvertes
énormément de oui j'ai évolué oh je suis
totalement différent de ce que j'étais
il y a 20 ans à tous les points de vue
et puis c'est là au point de religion au
point de vue politique
parce que quand je m'habille pas comme
il le veulent bah il me chalut alors
évidemment il faut bien il faut changer
à tous les points de vue mais j'ai eux
qui nous font changer nous eux ils ne
changent pas mais nous il faut changer
et vous croyez que c'est bien de changer
de mettre un casque
le soir avait après 21h c'est plus la
peine de sortir on risque de se faire
attaquer par des jeunes qui varient
entre
16 16 et 18 ans n'est-ce pas
ce n'est plus à comparer de dans mon
temps mais il y a bien longtemps aussi
mais ça nous prend grand chose
à part une perte d'exception je ne
trouve pas la jeunesse gay
on y croirait toujours avec du souci et
plutôt triste ils sont trop grattés et
ils n'ont jamais assez ce qu'il faut les
jeunes sont presque blasés maintenant
voyez-vous ils sont à peine à peine ils
peuvent marcher ils ont déjà une petite
bicyclette ils ont 7-8 ans ils ont une
petite moto ils attendent leur 17 ans 18
ans pour avoir le retour rien de bon
monsieur
parce qu'elle est trop dévergondé
et puis
[Musique]
ils ont leur tête ce qu'ils ont envie
leur faut
que ce soit dans n'importe quoi si
j'étais quelqu'un au pouvoir moi je
double les effectifs de la police et
alors avec ce qu'on appelle la
mitraillette à la main et puis tous les
petits rigolos qui font vraiment des
misères aux gens
les négligeants
intéressants il y en a qui ne sont pas
et pas il y a pas d'avis catégorique il
y a des vues avec qui on peut voir des
rapports intéressants des discussions
intéressantes autre chose que la pluie
et le beau temps ou autre chose que vous
êtes des sales jeunes vous avez les
cheveux longs vous voulez tout en l'air
et puis à côté de ça
les gens avec qui vraiment c'est
vraiment très bien quoi sur 100 je
voulais vous avez 70% de bon
20 à peu près bon et ils disent à
balancer à la poubelle les vieux c'est
un fouet de conservatif mais disons que
toute les trois quarts des idées
nouvelles donc qui arrive sont des idées
qui viennent des jeunes en général les
trois quarts du temps elles sont
infrénées par qui par les vieux les
jeunes et les personnes âgées maintenant
vous savez ne peuvent plus faire très
très bon ménage ils ont leur vie et leur
vie est beaucoup plus mouvementée que la
nôtre alors les mouvements thé tandis
que nous
leur nouvelle mode on reconnaît plus si
c'est une fille ou si c'est un garçon
et souvent il y en a des il y en a qui
sont polis mais il y en a qui sont pas
polis alors on dit
tu as vu le jeu là vous êtes catalogué à
partir d'un certain âge quel âge oh
disons 45 ans c'est terminé un peu plus
de 45 ans pour les jeunes
et encore on m'a dit encore vous ne
faites pas trop vieux qu'on m'a dit mais
finalement on dit le père Robin des
types de 35 ans donc jusqu'à 40 ans
écouter donc un roman qui me dit que
[Musique]
qu'attendez-vous de vos grands-parents
tout d'abord un accueil vachement
chaleureux qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
que ce soit le comportement d'un jeune à
votre égard par exemple
voilà tout ce qu'il me faudrait
je crois qu'on se confie beaucoup plus à
ses grands-parents qu'à ses parents
parce qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
disponibles
oui ils sont beaucoup plus accueillants
aussi et puis je crois qu'on éprouve
beaucoup plus de on éprouve du plaisir à
se confier à ces grands-parents parce
que ils se sont ils se sont utiles à ce
moment-là
quand il y a quelque chose d'important
vient d'abord raconter à m'aimer et puis
c'est un petit coup dur on vient d'abord
de le dire quoi qu'il y a un rapport
affectif important entre les enfants et
les grands-parents quelque chose naturel
qui est indispensable parce que je
trouve avec une mère en discutant et
bien qu'avec une grand-mère quoi
que si on a le contact encore beaucoup
avec nos petits-enfants c'est que
et bien ils ont toujours senti qu'il
était plus importants pour nous de les
accueillir eux que de faire attention à
nos meubles que de faire attention à
toutes nos affaires à tout ce qu'on
pouvait avoir notre tranquillité je
crois que ça a été très important on
appelle Seri des tables qui sont voilà
une série des hommes salaires voilà vous
avez des séries la dame soleil le brun
ou la voilà l'Europe
le brun Rollin voilà un autre Louis
Blanc un autre
Albert un autre
pour les petits enfants qui maintenant
c'est les jeunes bien sûr
nous sommes tout de même les vieux ça y
a rien à faire
c'est une loi naturelle à mon avis quand
nous avions stage là le grand-père moi
c'était le même cas il est mort à l'âge
que j'ai maintenant et j'avais 5 ans
c'était le vieux de la famille
naturellement vivait avec lui alors là
on a des souvenirs de son grand-père
tandis que aujourd'hui
dans les grands-parents ils habitent
chez eux d'ailleurs nous sommes encore
en activité
tandis qu'à ce moment-là aussi ils y
étaient mais alors dans les fermes les
travailler à la ferme ils étaient les
mêmes ils étaient les patrons tandis
qu'aujourd'hui sinon ce n'est plus que
ne sont plus les patrons ce sera le fils
qui sera le patron ou la fille les
grands-parents ont une vue beaucoup plus
sévère de l'éducation que nous à l'heure
actuelle et on essaye justement de se
rattraper sur les sur les restrictions
que l'on a eu de notre jeunesse
vis-à-vis de nos enfants actuellement et
les grands-parents ne comprennent pas
toujours mais c'est normal je crois
qu'il faut se mettre un petit peu à leur
place il y a des méthodes de travail qui
se permettent de critiquer
que nous dans les fermes mais qui
commence à travailler mais du grand père
il travaille comme il y a 100 ans alors
que c'est absolument faux c'est
simplement une bricole qui va faire
comme ça aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il y en
a plus qu'ils le font parce que ça ne
peut pas tourner il sujet de
conversation était beaucoup moins
important on projet par les politiques
on ne pouvait pas parler de religion il
fallait avoir l'opinion des
grands-parents nous nous a toujours
obligé à dire vous à nos grands-parents
en disant tutoyer les parents mais au
grand-parents on leur disait vous moi
on les a laissé nous tutoyer mais alors
j'ai exigé de mes enfants qui disent
vous à leurs grands-parents ils ont
quand même des idées enfin en l'issue
pas tellement très bien pour leurs idées
mais enfin ceux qui cherchent à
comprendre que le grand-père a eu des
compétences en son temps oui aujourd'hui
il croirait facilement qu'il ait dépassé
par les événements le jour mais enfin il
reconnaît quand même qu'il y a des
valeurs qui restent
lesquelles madame
l'expérience de leur vie qui a été rude
qui a quand même été valable enfin oui
pour nous c'est les parents qui sont les
grands-parents qui restent la preuve de
tout ça j'ai beaucoup rêvé de mes
grands-parents puisque j'ai des
pratiques pratiquement pas connues et
ça représente oui c'est vrai la mamie
gâteau et je suis très heureuse que mon
fils parce que j'ai un petit fils de 2
ans et demi et ses grands-parents de des
deux côtés et une arrière-grand-mère je
suis très heureuse de ça les
grands-parents dans le temps étaient
toujours fatigués d'avance
il n'hésitait ils hésitaient plutôt à
monter un escalier ou des choses comme
ça il y avait toujours un officiel mais
je sais pas quel truc nous on sait pas
encore ce que c'est du moins on croit le
pas de savoir il y avait une réputation
de d'être fatigué bon ben on était
grands-parents donc on était fatiguée
vous n'êtes pas des grands-parents
fatigués non non on voudrait surtout pas
l'être alors on est on s'est inscrit un
club de yoga en fait depuis 7 ans du
yoga et on a l'impression que ça nous
fait un énorme bien ça nous entretient
s'il vous plaît c'est si bien qu'on a on
a envie avec nos petits-enfants comme si
on était de leur âge bien sûr avec la
difficulté de l'âge mais on se met à
quatre pattes avec les tout petit et on
discute et on fait du sport avec
[Musique]
vous pensez que votre affection votre
amour leur est nécessaire
oui étant donné qu'ils sont un peu
perdus dans le présent à mon avis ou
ils ont besoin de sentir quelqu'un près
d'eux dans une civilisation qui
finalement est passée très vite de l'âge
passé un âge nouveau ils ont besoin d'un
appui les uns apportent la spontel la
spontanéité les eaux de la sagesse
l'expérience qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
prises au cours de leur vie c'est
quelque chose de très important et une
famille c'est un grand parent
une famille incomplète il manque quelque
chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]